Now we turn to the concept
of a vertex cover,
which will play a role analogous to the
one played by the concept of minimum cut
in our discussion of maximum flows.
Given a graph, G,
we say that S is a vertex cover
if every edge is incident
on a vertex in S.
Thus we say that S covers all the edges.
Take this graph for example here.
If we include this vertex,
then we cover these three edges.
Including this vertex covers
these three more, and
this vertex includes these more edges.
And lastly,
we need to cover this edge here so
we'll ad this vertex here as well.
One pretty easy observation
to make about a vertex cover
is that its size serves
as an upper bound for
the size of a matching in a graph
as stated in the proposition here.
The proof is simple.
Clearly for every edge int he matching
at least vertex must be in the cover,
and of course all these
vertices must be distinct
because no vertex is
in two matched edges.